die zurück
[Musik]
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer adventure web beziehungsweise
einer kleinen mini game matt und zwar
dort zusammen mit dem kran kraft da der
hier direkt erstmal abgekratzt ist jeder
gefahr da mensch kate spade ja ist so
ich habe sie getötet ich bin so ein
scheiß china geschieht wenn es jetzt
noch mal machst du wenn du mich in der
zeit kraft da ist zwar nicht so toll
crafter aber ich war als ich bin einfach
ein stadtmensch etat in die kommentare
oder wie ihr seht also ja jetzt sind es
gut also erstmal wir spielen jetzt hier
und hier
die singleplayer und die also wir sind
multiplayer aber das einfach weil wir
bei abos sind command blogs und an wir
haben monster an wir dürfen nur blöcke
auf claim-blöcken setzen
wir dürfen keine blöcke kaputtmachen und
also wir sind hier irgendwie aufgewacht
und haben hier keinen plan wo wir sind
und wissen aber wir sind hoffnungslos
verloren jetzt noch eine message telekom
crafter wie komm wir machen wir du bist
billy kran kräfte what do you want out
of warcraft beantwortet einfach wir
machen es einfach zu 23 hätten das spiel
nicht gehen hier sind ein paar sachen
drin nimmt ja auch etwas raus jetzt hast
du fast es gleich so wie ich auch
hc f wir wollen so magst du bist aber
leise macht man ja aus den klassen
claim-block bin ich immer noch weise
immer irgendwie place blogs und
klebrigen aufsetzen jetzt geht's wir
müssen ja irgendwie was drauf setzen
oder so mal eben mal meinen lautstärke
ein bisschen höher jetzt wahrgenommen
wir müssten irgendwas drauf setzt also
ich mache es mir jetzt hier change 1 und
works challenge hahaha steht da wie man
die tankuhr swan of you tell me why i
hate you always make fun of film
breaking the waves in charge of the
matter what you're likely format ohne
wolf pack wellness wie auch von mailgate
hieß the one who challenge can take time
fliplife zu beginn mag ich hab da nichts
dran strukturen scheitern
ich komme auch nicht dann macht man mal
nix im schatten gedrückt dass
irgendwelche aufgegangen von den village
bei den managern in den denk dran
hallo oder mach mal platz bitte links
machen wir den block kaputt ist es nicht
so einfach links von uns den kopf ist am
berg nein das ist doch bestimmt gefallen
ich irgendwo unter oder so ich glaube
nicht wir müssen nach vorne ist ein
knopf wir müssen uns gleich etwas
geniales überlegen was wir machen können
war das so
indirektes ganze zeit weil wir nehmen
das ist eventuell darin also diesmal
somit direkt in einer aber natürlich ist
es auf jeden fall
ach wir müssen da glaube ich irgendwas
anschmeißen oder ganz schnell kann das
sein
das könnten machen ich kriege auch
erstmal message ich habe was geworfen
und nichts passiert aber es hat sich
wieder geschlossen hätte ich ja was
häufig drücke er okay jetzt hat sich
geschlossen kommt schnell wir müssen
sachen werfen
[Gelächter]
da sind doch irgendwie da sind doch
irgendwie so dinges diese fotos all mein
bruder auch kurden
ich habe es einmal aufzuspringen die man
nach hinten da ist da dieser die sa will
steht in dem ding da drin
der musste doch mal irgendwie raus gehen
wie sie gehen ja nicht raus keine ahnung
wahrscheinlich ist dass er unser unser
feind ja und da muss jetzt auf rot auf
grün laufen aber wie können wir ihnen
dazu bringen dass sie überhaupt sich mal
läuft da will ich jetzt noch mal durch
die meinen etwas vorlauf your child
enemies also das war einer unserer
kindheit feinde
okay er hat er uns gehasst soll steht
noch mit dem actionfilm break ist da
ach so das würden wir immer machen leute
nein ich weiß nicht vielleicht lauten
die auf irgendwas immerzu die dings die
welle tor laufen die auf irgend eines
von den items zu ja das kann sein
da müssen wir die einfach mal fotos
glass werfen dann laufen die da
vielleicht hinter laufenden auf die
druckplatte es kann aber auch sein dass
die leute kräftig habe ich fünf hielt
weil du ich fühle mich hier wie hast du
das denn für ein zugemacht max hier kann
ich hab was geworfen wir müssen den
schalter in die wieder drücken gedrückt
mal den hier vorne
assist wieder zu ist es zu null wir sind
draußen
ah ja das war angezogen dieses ding ich
weiß nicht warum macht er ist auf die
dings platte gegangen hätte aber was
steht denn also lieber als den start auf
dem norma what you're likely von medal
of honor ist ja fies wie alpha also beim
normalen so werden wir schon drei mal
gestorben aber es ja minecraft also also
wir haben den ganzheit damals der abt
und so was alles und jetzt ärgert er hat
uns klar knopf little friend is you next
challenge ist ein kleines der lask ist
eine kiste wie ich hab mich ja okay
jetzt komm raus ich gebe ihnen jemals
wörtlich ich werde den hier vor ich habe
angst zu sterben ich danke
okay halt direkt die hätten wir nicht
verloren aber doch noch mal machen oder
haben die pinnwand orie soll ich jetzt
auch junge du penner drückt er auf lasst
mich doch erst mal ein schweizer
wir sind draußen buch junge cooler typ
alter danke wurde die danke kein ding
also der ist jemand ein vorziehen
exchange so jetzt müssen wir den kita
reinschmeißen ja zurück
cd
[Musik]
aixtron von dazu bündnis pro wozu
teleportiert nein
also ich wohl portiert jetzt bin ich
gestorben
leute ja man muss immer von anfang an
durchlaufen alter da muss jetzt auch
noch mal ich wollte mich nicht
teleportiert nur der der fälle
wahrscheinlich ein tier 1 geworfen würde
und steht nicht auf der auf dem ding ja
komm süßer kommt max wir brauchen zwei
keys die wieder reinschmeißen kommen
hierher kommt er her kommt wirklich ist
so richtigen nutzer alte maxime brauchen
wahrscheinlich zwei christie wieder
reinschmeißen halo da ist kein er ist
kein kiel jetzt oder vielleicht ist als
neuer egal wir müssen uns was nehmen
weil sonst geht es ja nicht oder
was die leute schaffe ich das alter wer
du bist sterben dann werden wir wieder
zurück kommt hier erwarte deswegen
probiere ich ja gerade ich müsste das
eigentlich schaffen den sprung
er selber sei schwierig nach zweieinhalb
herzen zwei herzen anderthalb herzen ein
herz ein halbes schaff ich das wieder
ein herz neu besetzt
ich bin direkt neben die reingesprungen
cool max das ist sehr loyal von dir ja
das schätze ich auf jeden fall sehr
gespannt und steht direkt da der gute
mann luca wir müssen uns wohl die dinger
holen oder ja wir müssen uns die
schalter und wir müssen die beide
reinschmeißen war eigentlich banal aber
wohl nicht repetiert also ist es auch
keinen schicken
doch du bist ja gestorben da eigentlich
nicht okay lkw-maut 1 neben einfach
irgendwas dagegen muss wahrscheinlich
nichts bestimmt na ja doch es gibt so
kombination dass das eventuell was
bestimmtes sein muss als ob mich das an
und wertige denn kochen glaube ich ja
unter welchen punkt finde ich das
ziemlich geben bei der suche
trotzdem ist okay was passiert nix den
ding drin
es ist schlecht dass ich mich gut herr
wieso nicht gibt es mir auch mal game
auf ich weiß in welche richtung wir
gegangen gegangen wären also da wo du
bist ok da macht dich selbst also wie
gesagt leute das ist wegen wie es ist ja
nur für den singleplayer aber wer jetzt
gedacht dass wir das hier zusammen so
ein bisschen erforschen
deswegen ich guck mal weg na also in
denen das ganze jetzt nicht so ernst in
den längen drin da ist nix passiert also
gerade ich habe nichts gemacht ja ich
bin auch noch da
ja es steht einfach da und bei der kiste
ist aber geschieht deswegen sehen wir
ihnen gerade nicht aber es ist ja
komisch weil auch wenn du gestorben
wärst du weißt ja einfach nicht normal
da hingekommen
ja ist also vielleicht ist der spieler
aber auch einfach wenn man das alter
geil jetzt hats geklappt jungen das ist
haben wir ist manchmal mit ein bisschen
frau gelang der pass lover lover ist
waiting for you
eigentlich wäre damit kommen wir müssen
uns diese blessings geben naja kannst du
das oder ich mache es mir ja bloß
bespuckt mich wie heißt die clientis
posten porsche noch bleiben das
irgendwie so ein magnet am sowie
pharming vielleicht ist es egal es geht
nicht es geht nicht ja ich finde es
nicht willst du mich nein du bleibst
hier max wir finden das natürlich also
das ist doch hier
ich weiß nicht was gibts echt nicht egal
ist aber egal wir schaffen das
wissenschaft der einfache ja ist echt so
freuen sich die läufer leuchtet ja so
also das hätten wir schon auch so
geschafft
ja klingt okay ich hab den gedrückt wer
ist no way you make up passt man extra
projekt funktioniert wieder
es kennt sie wer ist wer ist vorn
bringen
junge welchen wir drücken auf jeden fall
nicht den ganzen links oder das ist
bestimmt eine falle
ich glaube der ganzen welt die linke ist
besser ja irgendwann hat man sich ja
links gewinnt hört sich für mich hinein
und macht erstmal wieder game und 0 max
ebenfalls wir nicht therapiert werden
aber ich kann game hat nur geben wenn
wir es ja klar wir wir müssen ja
teleportiert werden jetzt ins lange eck
im kopf weil wir dachten was rein
schweiz müssten also haben wir immer von
anfang an durchlaufen also müssen wir
wieder das mit dem kopf aber ja ich bin
viel ganz links weil die anderen bei
allen bei anderen wäre es halt jeweils
mit 33 prozent chance und dann wäre es
einfach komplett zufällig aber links ja
ist keine 100 prozent chance ok ich hab'
links gedrückt
das ist irgendwie zu offensichtlich
finde ich es ist nichts passiert
ok ich drück mal den zweiten von rechts
okay
nein einfach ich töte dich wenn schon
du wirst du bist einfach schultes gesagt
wir sollen drücken dass am nächsten
stehe weiter in der lage war das nicht
vom anfang
chillig alter gaul magst du bist haben
so leise ich warte ich drehe mich lauter
besser vielleicht reguliert du dich
immer so wichtigen runter von selbst ja
das ist wenn dein sky junge dieser
scheiß typ soll mal wieder in seinen
dinge eingehen hätte ich mal dings
behalten all star game modes naja egal
das ist das doch kein das hat mir auch
schon geschafft sich und vorbringen ja
mach mal
ich probiere das schon noch ein bisschen
so du kannst hier bis zu hoch
das funktioniert alter killer kann ich
mir genauso gut folgen sehen wir jetzt
nach außen erinnert mich alles hier so
funktioniert dann für virtual oder bist
du wer spricht da rein mit den grotten
drin
ja man sollte schon geld macht daraus
machen das trotzdem haben so einfach
weil du kannst du heute draufgängern
sprint etwa durch heute alter wir sind
immer noch in der lage war dies einfach
nicht verschwunden ohne witz max es ist
wirklich so dass man glaube ich eine
challenge wenn man die nicht schafft und
dann stirbt dann ist man halt so wie
einst erhalte ich glaube das ist recht
so das portal
das heißt web funktioniert quasi aber
wenn man halt einmal dann nicht spielt
dann ist man halt tot
wie lange ist die aufnahme schon 14
minuten aber dass man trotzdem gucken
noch mal welchen schalter man gedrückt
hat oder wir zeigen euch wenigstens noch
die anderen challenges jetzt mal ja ihr
könnt ja selbst testen ob sie ob ihr
dann schafft wir haben definitiv nicht
geschafft zu überleben ich gebe es mal
hier raus so steht ja also diese kennt
ihr ja das ist ja dass mit diesem
skeletons kahl gewesen
das ist halt dieser weg den man gehen
musste das ist das mit der lava da wo
grad die lava drin ist und da ich weiß
nicht welcher schalter richtig gewesen
wäre also denkt erst mal wieder
solarwatt schließen
ganz rechts formaxx ja keine ahnung was
er richtig gewesen wäre also hier geht
es nicht sagt ein server erst richtig
gewesen wie es jetzt gemacht habe das
war spaß
wir leben auf geht's jungs wer ist wann
blog of water water blocks die band in
the water day of ethics
ein problem für unsere dings wir unseren
job los
leider nur einen pro hier auch keinen
knopf
wo hast du hast es geschafft jawoll
einfach eigentlich ne das geht gar nicht
goethe teklogix mustafa t pain oder so
kleine spaß hieß also nicht du sondern
die ja die zombies judas ist echt heftig
ja die sind heftig junge ich hab' ich
sterbe gleich von einem ich klicke ich
leg des todes darauf die sterben einfach
nicht ich hab's geschafft du auch ja ich
bin direkt hinter dir du bist halt
irgendwie voll von mir leute jetzt der
zwar auf die abgesehen kann töten wird
in der arena des todes
es geht um leben und tod
die reagieren wir uns beim echten zwar
wäre ich mit dir würde ich echt zu
reagieren ich hab den ausgang übrigens
gefunden nein doch wirklich nein ich
will wissen ob handy habe den ausgang
china gefunden
es ist der eingang ist aber vorhin hatte
ich wirklich den ausgang junge keine
ahnung ich weiß was lange da kommen
jetzt kommt das schon bisher zu stoppen
jung nein ich mache das ernsthaft sagt
da ist es passiert ja ich hab es aber
auch geschafft
an erster stelle wir sind voll die kraft
und zuschalten runde zu sterben junge ja
ohne ohne zu sterben alter egal jungs
fliegen dahinter zeigt euch zu den rest
das ist unmöglich das kann man einfach
nicht schaffen wo das bei dem krieg man
gerade eben echt nichts machen können
das ist wirklich so naja davor auch was
ist das deine schalter das ist einfach
nur raten wir sind ja eigentlich die
pros so hast du hier muss man
runterspringen dass das labor und dass
dieses komische behinderten level von
dort eben da ist das da war einfach mal
so ein krieg ich weiß nicht warum aber
man soll monster an machen bis jetzt hat
man jedoch gar nicht gebraucht ja doch
diese krippe die uns einfach so getötet
haben wenn ich glaube der ist einfach
jedes band ja okay ich werde zum
beispiel heruntergefallen und werde
jetzt mehr oder weniger tot gewesen
so werden es geschafft mensch max so
geile sau wie goethe parcours beiden
fighting auch hier und das macht
bestimmt spaß und eisen schwerterin ja
lasst das machen gamer 0
ja ich bin okay 100 kills
[Musik]
alter albums bond nichts ist so
irgendwie ist die map bisschen verbarg
das 730 bau neuer alter junge fallen
diese kleinen sind einfach nur
verwechselt das kann man nicht schafft
ihr es nur an alter das geht nicht
wir sehen also ihr habt ja gesehen hätte
das ist unglaublich des todes ist
scheiße ich glaube gegeben uns selbst
mal so ein bisschen die aristoteles oder
hsv
also ich meine nicht aber ich gebe mir
nur hose und links ich gebe mir
komplette rüstung bogen mit filmstar
fallen von gier schwer das wieder spaß
daran wenn man am anfang waren wir doch
ernsthaft dabei aber dann haben wir es
nicht geschafft und jetzt machen wir
wenigstens was lustiges da was also wenn
man es nicht schafft ihr könnt ja selber
mal eine video antwort senden obwohl
wieder und vergeblich damit wir können
das einfach schreiben video an konkreter
und dann ob er das schafft hier halt
oder nicht ja wenn ihr das in einem in
einem anlauf schafft dann habt ihr echt
mein respekt dann teilen wir das auch
auf facebook und alles wenn ihr das in
einem anlauf schafft und instagram nennt
es nennt escon crafter später gaylord 0
ich mache auch gamer es geht nichts
wahrscheinlich denn die ganzen sbornaja
die sind wirklich gespannt der egal dass
man das mal gucken was hier so danach
gekommen
vielleicht kommen wir noch mal welche
ich weiß viele event wenn schon denn
schon werden die alle gekommen das heißt
hast du ja vielleicht kommen einfach
noch mal welche na ja schon da sein dann
ist es unmöglich es kommt halt einfach
keiner neumarkt das ist einfach traurig
es ist einfach es ist einfach unmöglich
ich habe da zwei kills glaube ich mit
diamant rüstung die avant schwert wurde
ja ich setze jetzt einfach lava und da
verbrennen die alle dritte sieht es aus
ja ich bin auf dem weg zu dir vor es ist
also nichts sollte dieses übels habe die
zerstören mich alter hat gesehen dass
wir mittlerweile zugrunde gerichtet
konsolidiert sind ja auf mich fokussiert
sie dachte ich okay werden sie gekehrt
noch ein level geschafft zu spiel spaß
gerade eben habe ich keine gefahren
eines wird die mehr als 70 nicht
verbrennen - mehr als wenn hier so übel
zu viele zombies sind muss sie an der
decke fahren dann ins gangster hier ist
einfach mal war ajax nicht nicht hexen
hexen ach so da ich das sagen verhexen
gespannt also nee hab ich nicht wieso
ich zaubern
ok jetzt probieren wir was aus ja das
ist auf jeden fall hammergeil macht das
ganze auch richtig spaß auf jeden fall
[Musik]
soll ich die wege gucken erst mal weiter
was sie danach so gekommen wäre
also dann hätte man da hätte man dings
bekommt man hätte auf jeden fall etwas
geld haben müssen so was das hier auch
das ist tnt ronja da wäre ich auch schon
wieder gestorben
teheran kenzo oder dieses mini em leute
ich lebe dein leben lebe noch
ich hab's geschafft kennst du das
minigame tnt man muss sogar ganz viele
sachen drüber reden und hinter der
explodiert halt alles das volk alt ist
hat man ja mal spielen könnt ihr in die
kommentare
ich habe es echt geschafft also ich
hätte das auch geschafft wenn wir da
weiter gekommen und dann hier completed
okay wir haben es geschafft
also ist auf jeden fall krass wenn ihr
das alles in einem durchlauf schafft
dann nennt ist einfach con crafter kita
vor irgendwas und dann fegte auf jeden
fall die szene aber wir müssen auf
youporn jetzt doch weiter einmal battle
machen jeder mit schwert und mit
kompletter riss und pfeilen wenig mit
die rüstung sagen die mit leder rüsten
jetzt nicht so lange dauert
agadir schwer ja oder mit alwin rist
umrüstung der schwert und bogen und
pfeile bin dabei
[Musik]
der moment für den für die zeit auf ps
voll oder das wenig von mobs ein beweis
nicht so wichtig
als ich bin im gaylord 00 aber
unentschieden
naja unentschieden okay ich bereit ja
bloß wenn ja wo willst du es unsichtbar
bei mir ja ok los
[Musik]
eine battle junger wald wird übrigens
auch mal ein battle mit maxi mir kommen
ja aber in survival games bette auf
einer neuen map und das wird richtig
sexy eurocom sogar man kann nicht gegen
kraft verdiene das in minecraft
minecraft grundregeln ich hab gesagt
ohne luca hat er steht einfach direkt
hinter dir und greift ich nicht an
das ist ja wie als youtube servern zu
zocken
alle verfolgen dich in gottes schutz von
als alter
hab mir nur wenige leben junge ohne
essen ist lottes gedroppt ist das egal
es war trotzdem essen
was nicht
[Musik]
ja komm geil geil da ist nicht goethe
beim battle los
ja was ich will das gebiss alter war
sagte einmal ich bin schlecht wie viel
leben hatte stoner sechseinhalb ja du
hast die odyssee im dem gamertag
rassischer ich habe nicht mehr
regeneriert also schön aber ich würde
gern noch eine revanche an
ja ok wollte der revanche sehen einfach
nur ein battle max gegen ich wollen wir
das mal machen wo wir einfach auf den
server gehen und steht uns irgendwie 20
minuten ausrüsten oder so und dann
einfach betteln oder wir spielen mit
hacks it und neben der pistole
nein ich werde jetzt so locker wie
simple erstmal okay wenn du schreibst
dann die kommentare ob ihr sowas volt
eventuell ja sogar morgen oder keine
ahnung und irgendwie sowas ob ihr das
haben wolltest mag sich dann beide
aufnehmen dann bereiten wir uns wir sind
halt in skype miteinander und klatschend
über themen aber wir bereiten uns halt
neben nebenbei so heftig vor
jetzt hab ich nur noch vom herzen
übrigens ne richtig trotzdem du bist
einfach der größte kakao auf der
kompletten welt ja geil alter das ist
fair das ist geil sogar wieder gewinnen
der nennt sich pvp proalter weil gott
nein das ist einfach nur schlecht und
gleicht der zwei zu eins für mich recht
unfair und und leute hätte team des
todes du willst doch selbst schuld also
video hier auftritt
die nehmen sich ein beispiel an dir
weißt du
man hätte mich auf und töten dich ist es
liste sphären und und ungleich ist es
wieder so weit wie wir eben problem hast
du wieviel leben hast du 5000 naja
jugend wenn es euch gefallen hat
trotzdem gefallen hat dann werden wir
uns definitiv bei einer bewertung freuen
und dann wenn ihr ein battle sehen wollt
dann schreibt das einfach in die
kommentare und dann sehen wir uns dann
wieder und dann würde ich sagen
definitiv erst mal wirklich einfach voll
mit pfeil in der leben drin hast du
schon auch noch mal auch klar habe ich
noch nicht viel weiter wie sich nochmal
getötet haben
[Musik]